first up we got Christoph who's saying
hello thank you so much for your
inspiring an educational video uh you're
so helpful to my life my question is how
do you find good people to work with to
scale your business kristef should I go
back to the look what I deal with them
Evan he'll know this one of our he's a
legend in terms of the business person
i'm steve jobs so christoph his quote is
famous quote you know the deep big d
motor hashtag number one demotivator for
talented people is to have to put up
with bozos so Steve Jobs said nothing is
more frustrating than a players having
to work with B players whoo-hoo
absolutely number one slowed them down
and to suck their energy from them so
the best thing you can do is as a leader
obviously as hire great people and Steve
Jobs said it's better than giving the
first fell off or sushi free sushi you
want to hire a player so how do you do
that that's the crux you question I
think number one um you have obviously a
brand out there a big idea and I think
actually if you do that well it attracts
great people second they are always
always go out to your network and we
sort of talked about on previous
broadcasts about how you go out attract
really good people but first we'll
identify them you know if you're working
in a company today or you starting off
in your own people who really impress
you and people who consistently kind of
knock the ball out the path there be
great targets to join your personal
crusade in your business so I think a
lot of it is around kind of networks
obviously things like linkedin and stuff
like that make it even easier but I
think most of all you really want to
build a business and a company that
attracts the very best attract rock
stars and probably the most important
thing you can do is a growing business
actually probably the most important
thing is to actually invest your time
making really smart eyes and candidly I
made bad hires in my life I've made lots
of mistakes and if you do many lots of
mistakes and yeah on hiring it's
somewhere where it can hurt you but if
you haven't made a mistake let's be
honest everybody's done it and what you
got to do is really be honest with
itself and have the honest conversation
the first day of heart and it you know
cut loose if they're not happy and
they're not going to make it in your
company you're much better off having
someone really motivated and really
capable to do that job but the best way
to do it is build a great company great
brand and that will actually draw you
know the bees to the honey pot just
always keeping an eye out for talented
people whether you're at a networking
event whether you're going to sage
summit whether you're you know at a
conference whatever it is if you see
somebody who really impresses you and
there might be a way to work together on
it on a project you have coming up you
always want to you're always looking for
you always want to keep that in mind
you're looking for talented people that
help join and build this thing you're
creating if you're posted out on social
media you know Steve and taco having a
really galvanizing message and something
powerful that people want to come and be
attracted to our people respond to that
if somebody who's going above and beyond
and you know if you're looking for a
programmers or somebody on there it was
like sharing the programming skills and
you can ask to join your team you know
people who love your mission already I
think it's great to be able to involve
them in what you're doing so the steamer
I'm thinking now you know when you came
to Sage it's still you know relatively
new i guess it hasn't been something
you've been at for 20 years now you come
over how did you go about building your
team obviously the team in place you
bringing new people on as well how do
you think about the people that you
surround yourself with there yeah you
know one of the most critical things we
had to do was hard huge talent and we
made a lot of changes in the team so
just a few data points we've got about
14,000 people but I think it's a lot of
about capabilities some experience and
attitude but if you've got attitude and
you've got desire it's amazing what you
can overcome so we've actually kind of
really focused on our and Millennials
we've really focused on a much better
gender balance so in the senior
management team I'm really pleased to
say I think we've now gone up from about
twenty two percent female it's now
thirty two percent and that's just in
less than a couple of years so there's
loads of elements not just capability
but it comes back to that culture you
want to build you want to be an
inclusive company a come
me which is obviously high-performing
but also a company that really
encourages young people to come in and
learn and rotate through their careers
that they can go you know into one
function and go off and we you know it's
great actually I'm in Vancouver melody I
called Tom Goff who used to work in the
London office now he's working in
Vancouver in a 27 28 year old guy and
time-worn an opportunity if we can
create a company where people
individuals colleagues have huge
aspirations and their aspirations and
their dreams touch and connect with sage
so that they can make career but I'd
also say Evan you know i met i'm a 23
year old entrepreneur this morning who
blew me away ago called jack and jack
has just started the company's got I
think he's closing around to get about
eight million of funded but what
impressed we were jacked firstly he
contacted me on Twitter he said kind of
have a cough with you the answer was yes
he's done that with Ronan Dunne who's a
rock star at verizon he's done it with
superb female entrepreneurs and he's
just assembled an unbelievable little
company well you know a dozen people but
he's also done that through just
perspiration hard work hard graft and
being bold and asking people and
actually you know quote is if you don't
ask you don't get so I think when you're
looking for talent it's exactly say save
some all these great conferences you go
to look a network and find out who the
stars are share with a new big idea in
your vision and you always find people
gravitate to leaders and fantastic
business ideas as well and a mission and
a good cause with a great culture